if you have an addiction that brings you
great shame or just a nasty nasty bad
habit that you for some reason can't
stop doing or even if you have something
that is a good thing that you want to
start doing maybe it's going to the gym
maybe you want to be the type of person
who goes to the gym but you just can't
bring yourself to do it maybe you have
done it successfully a couple days in a
row usually during the new year but
something always happens you do the new
good thing for a little bit or you stop
doing the bad thing for a little bit but
a couple days in you start to feel it
it's like a mounting pressure and all of
a sudden you have one bad day a day
where maybe you were a little bit too
lazy to go to the gym or maybe you were
a little bit too weak in the willpower
Department to not do the bad thing that
you're avoiding and it feels like the
whole thing comes crashing down you
lament it's like the House of Cards
finally came crumbling down and you
binge yourself to death on the thing you
are trying to avoid or the old lifestyle
that you were trying to get away from if
this has been your story with sticking
to a new habit change or trying to
change your life in any meaningful way
then there's a very good chance that
you've been falling for the myth of
vertical progress what is the myth of
vertical progress I don't know if it's a
result of Internet self-improvement
culture or recent studies in habit
formation psychological something or
other but everybody seems to have this
idea that if they just make it to a
certain amount of days then everything
will make sense they fetishize 21 days
or 30 days or 90 days 365 days they
think to themselves damn me in this
piece of mode right now if I could only
make it to 90 days then everything would
make sense 90 day me is legit he just
feels better about himself he lives a
better life he's not by bothered by
trivial things because he's sort of
gigachad viewing lifestyle change like
this is viewing progress as a vertical
thing you know you stack day two on top
of day one day three on top of day two
and then when the stack of days gets big
enough then your life changes and the
wild thing is almost everyone thinks
this way for some reason we think in
terms of streaks but the issue is that
no habit that you currently have was
ever built like this even if you thought
you were building your habit that way
the reality of this situation is that
every single successful day that you had
you were building progress you were
strengthening the muscle of that new
lifestyle so many of us believe that in
order to change our entire lives all we
need to do is hit a certain amount of
days and then everything will make sense
it's like nothing really matters up
until that point but then we hit that
magical number and our lives change
forever and even if you don't believe
that sort of dramatic narrative there's
still a subconscious understanding that
oh if I just hit this amount of days
then things will become easier what was
once unnatural will feel natural you
know it'll officially be locked in as a
habit and then I don't need to try very
hard anymore it's just automatic but the
problem is not only is this type of
thinking psychologically inaccurate but
it also adds so much pressure to hit
this magical day we're approaching
lifestyle change as if it's a Jenga
Tower you know you stack days on top of
days on top of days and eventually at
the top you hit your goal but the
problem with the Jenga Tower is that
with each block you add it becomes more
unstable so this pressure of messing up
becomes bigger and bigger and bigger the
more days you have under your belt and
when you think like this it almost
always feels as if though if you make it
really far like halfway say your goal is
90 days and you make it 45 days if you
mess up after 45 days it's almost like
the floodgates are open you're like oh I
knew I couldn't do it and then all of a
sudden you binge into the old behavior
and you figure maybe three years from
now I'm gonna try again but the thing is
progress is not vertical it's never been
vertical we're not building a tower
we're building a road a road that we're
planning on taking for the rest of our
lives a road that we do take with each
day that we partake in that new activity
because every single habit that you have
is just a road that leads you to a
desired destination even your bad habits
you do them because you get something
out of it you know they give you some
sort of feeling that you want to feel
the problem is that over time as we walk
a certain road we learn that this road
is actually pretty treacherous you know
it hurts us in the long run maybe it's
infested with Wolves maybe there are
slopes that make you slip and muddy your
clothes maybe it's a super inefficient
route and you're traveling and
exhausting yourself way longer than you
need to in order to get your desired
outcome whatever the case is not all
roads are created equal sometimes we
establish roads very early in our lives
that lead us to this destination that we
want but we learn as we get older that
there are way more efficient and
healthier routes to get to that result
and this road that we established that
we laid all these bricks on and created
this highway on no longer serve us the
reward it proposes is no longer worth
the injury we inflict upon ourselves by
taking this road so we decide through
our conscious effort to start
constructing a new road and a lot of the
time taking this new road to this same
destination that we want a road that is
less treacherous a road that won't hurt
us as much it'll take some work because
a lot of the time you know you know day
one day two day three we're all
motivated to sort of bushwhack and
create this new road through the weeds
but in the long run we know that this
new road is going to be way better way
more efficient and just a road that we
want to walk and every single day that
we opt for this new road instead of the
old one the old one is starting to grow
over you know some weeds are starting to
take effect there's some overgrowth
starting to develop and every single day
that we spend working on this new road
it becomes more comfortable and more
likely that we use this road in the
future because we are telling our brain
that yes this road leads to what we want
so this new lifestyle that you've been
working on that you occasionally try
every January 1st it's still there it's
always been there but the degree to
which it's developed is solely based on
how much you've been using it and just
because you have a bad day and you
understandably choose the old road one
day it doesn't mean that that road that
new road you're trying to build doesn't
exist anymore maybe you were tired maybe
you didn't want to bushwhack that day I
get it the old road probably looks very
tempting maybe you forgot why you were
building the new road but just because
you picked the old road one day doesn't
mean all of your progress is lost on the
new road you're building it's not and it
feels so much better and more
encouraging to know that the longer that
you spend developing the new road
planting bricks in Solid Ground day
after day that old road is starting to
get overgrown the more time you spend on
this new road through conscious effort
the easier this road becomes to walk not
harder there is no mounting pressure so
if you mess up after one day and you
want to burn the whole thing down that's
entirely up to you you can go back back
and start removing bricks on this new
Road Brick by Brick but just know that
it will be through conscious effort
because it doesn't just explode
automatically you can choose to abandon
your new building project and let the
weeds grow over so that the next time
that you try it again you have to Bush
whack right from the start again but it
will reveal a road that was already
there that you placed through effort so
it'll be just that much easier to start
up on that new road again so hopefully
this is a profoundly encouraging thought
changing your entire life has never been
about okay let's see how far we can go
with this and if I have one bad day well
it was worth a shot guess we'll try
again three years from now it's like no
we're in the business of developing new
defaults
like deep grooves to sink into day by
day we place a new brick we whack a new
weed until this road is a far more
comfortable road to travel to get what
we want and then eventually by using
this new road more and more and more The
Old Road will start to get consumed by
overgrowth it will become a road that
just feels very questionable you know
it's like oh why would we choose that
road when this road is so much better
that we've built but it just takes some
time to get there relinquish yourself of
the pressure of vertical progress it
doesn't exist stop chasing these
arbitrary numbers that have absolutely
no resemblance to living your life day
by day decision by decision try to find
ways to make building this new road as
easy and as efficient as possible remind
yourself constantly of why you're
building this new road and try to help
yourself develop it so that it's one
that you prefer taking 10 times out of
10. Let The Old Road die away and become
infested with parasites I don't know
what that was that was kind of stupid
let's build some roads
and I want you guys to download the
audiobook Atomic Habits by James Clear
using today's video sponsor audible I
know you've heard this title and this
author so many times but there is a
reason for it it's an endlessly
re-readable book and it reminds you that
every single time you do a new lifestyle
thing that you want to do it makes it
more likely that you do that thing in
the future not less likely that doesn't
make any sense so if you already have
Audible download that audiobook it is
worth it and if you don't have Audible
and you don't know what that is audible
is the leading provider of spoken word
entertainment and audiobooks all in one
place every single month they send you
one credit which you can spend on any
audiobook of your choice regardless of
cost and you get to keep that audiobook
forever if you ever cancel your
subscription you still keep your entire
library of audiobooks audible members
also get instant access to a rapidly
expanding catalog of audible Originals
podcasts and exclusive series including
some really cool Graham Hancock stuff
about alternate history what do you know
it's an audible original so if you want
to start building some new roads in your
life and start expanding your brain then
if you use my link in the description
below or text better ideas to 500 500
you'll get a 30-day free trial so once
again click on my link in the
description below or just text better
ideas to 500 500 to get your 30-day free
trial and thanks again to Audible for
sponsoring this video if you liked this
video make sure that you actually hit
the like button because when you hit the
like button the algorithm blesses me and
it shoves my bald head into other
people's homepages helping them out
which also helps me out so it is a
win-win for everybody involved if you're
lurking here and this is the thousandth
billionth beep bop am I going insane
probably consider hitting the Subscribe
button so that you don't miss future
videos that's I don't even know why I
say that that's not true because you
even if you hit subscribe you probably
like marginally more likely to see my
videos who knows what the algorithm will
do but you can influence it to some
degree by liking commenting and
subscribing either way thank you so much
for watching and we'll catch you in the
next video